have you spoken with your father
recently he called but I did not pick up
so you said a boundary and you notice
you have a kitten hidden in your purse
were you hiding it from me I think our
hour is up
oh you finally called me back you got
kicked out of your home didn't you we
can't have men of such low moral
integrity bringing down the place oh
please dad needs a place to stay last
time dad stayed with me the FBI followed
me to work for a week I would take him
but he's a horrible example for Henry
does this mean I'll get to see you guys
no I would put him on a plane I'm not
driving that he'd cross country but I'd
like to spend some time with you -
absolutely not
there's $200,000 course we've in fact I
can't unload it on my own I'll help you
did you change my navigation she gave me
$20 Henry blondies people old friends of
your grandfather's don't inhale you know
we cannot take any more dogs Comerford
Pied Piper of mange they know why
complain about Jack so much I like
don't hurt my kids I got through it but
he's different what I'd like to know who
that's going to oh I want to see him no
are you a sight for sore eyes he's the
worst possible hand for me I tell misty
that all the time
please tell me misty is your cat you
want me to tell you Misty's my cat who
is she
my cat she's your wife isn't she she is
set a boundary hello it's a line in the
sand the concrete actually morning
[Applause]
family that's all it is I used to be
able to make you laugh
mr. left
wife yeah I thought you were Buddhist
who I am but you bring out the right
wing Christian
[Music]